what's up guys it is Jerry as you can do
um I'm just cruising around and I'm here
to talk to you about another movie
because what else would I be doing so
yeah this is a week of that this is a
bit of a change of pace you know from
the for the kind of movies we normally
review over the weekend I went out with
some family and I got to see a movie
that's been out for a minute so I guess
this isn't so much a first impression as
it is like a delayed reaction but anyhow
we over the weekend saw a film called
boyhood which is the new film from
Richard Linklater who's the guy you
might recognize from the before films
before sunset before sunrise before
midnight was the last one they made that
he also did school of rock and dazed and
confused Bernie last year a couple years
ago and this film is something special
it's a long-running project of his I
guess and let's talk about it so this
film boyhood em is a coming-of-age story
about you know a young boy growing up
from you know the ages of roughly seven
to 18 or so and this film is is is
really incredible both content wise and
formally because first and foremost this
film was shot over the course of 12
years Richard Linklater wanted to tell a
story about a boy growing up and so the
relationship he has with his parents and
whatnots and the people around him all
circulating around the time of you know
first through 12th grade just before he
goes off to college so this was shot
over the course of 12 years it was
originally called the 12-year project
and I guess what they did was they would
just meet up for a few weeks every year
and you know continue shooting
continuing the story
and this is it's really incredible this
movie came together I mean Richard
Linklater is known you know sort of for
being a collaborator you know the before
films you know he worked really closely
with Ethan Hawke and Julie Delpy and
they all wrote the script together they
all weighed in on those characters
together and it's really collaborative
process and from what I've read they did
the same thing here with all the main
cast where they would meet up you know
discuss the script they would tailor the
script to things going on in the actors
lives especially I would imagine our
Coltrane who plays Mason who is the main
character I mean this movie gives you
insight and focuses on a lot of
different characters throughout but
Mason is sort of your main drive for the
story so all the actors weighed in on
the script and everything was sort of
subject to changing and morphing just
around life and you know they would
check in every couple years to continue
shooting and it's really amazing that
all these people stuck around and saw
this thing through which right there I
got to applaud everybody involved
because that's you know that's a special
thing especially because they couldn't
sign contracts because there are laws in
place you know prohibiting you from from
contracting people for such a long time
but this movie is pretty incredible to
watch you know you see these actors you
know growing and changing over time you
know for real you know you you see
Patricia Arquette and Ethan Hawke as
well as Lorelei Linklater who plays
their daughter the sister of Mason who's
the main character and Mason is played
by a young man by the name of LR
Coltrane you could see these people i'll
change for the younger actors you get to
see them grow up you get to see their
you know acting shift and grow it's
really interesting just in format alone
and then when you scratch the surface of
the the content of the story it's even
better I mean this story like i said is
a coming-of-age story and it's just sort
of about life it's one of those life
movies one of the things this movie does
such a good job at is just capturing
that sort of vastness of life you know
that the grayness that comes
you know day to day living and just
trying to figure out how to do it right
you know this movie sort of touches on
something at a certain point where it's
like everybody even the people you look
up to is having all the answers are sort
of muddling through the day and and
trying to figure it out everyone's
trying to figure out what their purpose
is and what you know really makes them
happy and what's worth living for you
know it's not an easy movie but there is
humor and there is drama and it's just
very real it just feels very real and
very natural and it's very resonant you
know and I think everyone will sort of
find a different thing to relate to in
this even if you don't relate to the
specific points of the story the
specific experiences you know you can
still relate to what it says about life
and that essence because we've all been
through that to one extent or another
you know figuring out who you are and
what you're into it and what's really
worth it it's all very gray and that's
part of what's so wonderful about this
movie is it really encompasses that but
in a way that is gripping and that feels
you know worth it nobody's all good or
all bad everyone's kind of exploring and
you can see how all these characters
might have got this way and it does
address or at least touch upon some of
these really tricky situations you come
across when you're growing up and and
you know those moments when you figure
out that maybe mom or dad or whoever
doesn't have all the answers and you
watch these little nuggets just these
little formative experiences start to
take toll and it's it's fascinating to
watch you know a life unfold that way
even if it is fiction it's like you know
the boundary between reality and fiction
is blurring an alarming rate these days
but this is sort of the opposite side of
that coin to me kind of is like we see
that a lot these days you know the news
and reality TV you know we're sort of
trying to push life into the movie mold
and this is sort of the opposite of that
where we're taking art and we're really
injecting you know daily life into it
this sort of takes art and makes it a
lot like life instead of the other way
around and you know it's just I'm really
glad that someone
is thinking outside the box like this
and is doing this kind of thing because
it's really unlike anything you've seen
before I think you know at least in this
format so definitely check this movie I
mean the performance is really good too
you know you've got ethan hawke and
patricia arquette as at least you know
his sort of two main parent figures um
they're a lot more people in here but
they're fantastic in this Lorelei
Linklater who's Richard Linklater's
actual daughter plays Mason's sister and
lr Coltrane who plays Mason by the end
of it I mean he's a great actor he does
a really good job with this and I'm sure
you know part of that is because it's
real you know or at least based on you
know real stuff for him but he doesn't
really good job he's really compelling
and he really you know holds your
attention and thing about this movie is
that I get the sense that a lot of at
least a lot of the younger actors aren't
you know actors aren't aren't you know
professional you know pursuing this
full-time some of the performances are
better than others but even the
performances that are a little more
green add to the realism in a sense and
the way the movies is paced and edited
reflects the way you you think back on
life and the things that you remember I
mean it's a series of moments some of
them are you know landmarks you know
like this is the time when we moved here
or some of them are just more isolated
moments just little things that you
remember like you know this is the day
we both rode bikes down here or you know
this was the day we found that thing
while we were hiking you know so it's
it's really interesting because you get
all the elements of life that way you
know you get the broad strokes you get
the fine details to you know the random
things you remember that you can realize
affected you so much and those are all
sort of really well displayed here you
know then that adds to the essence of
life
this movie has you know life is all
kinds of things you know it's difficult
it's confusing it's gray it's beautiful
it's joyous you know it's all kinds of
things in between and this movie you
know has all of those moments so it's
really well done in all regards it's
well-put-together it's not super stylish
in the way it's shot but it is shot
really well then there's a lot of really
great music in there that sort of
provides these touchstones from year to
year of where they are in time and stuff
like that and Richard Linklater knows
how to put together a soundtrack so this
movie is sort of a win for me on on all
fronts you know I think it's really
affecting its really well put together
and you know it's exciting cinema and
I'm really happy to see this so you know
it's different from a lot of stuff we
talked about what it's definitely worth
checking out it's a fantastic movie and
it's you know really that's a piece are
you know so I definitely feel really
positive on this it's one of my favorite
movies of the year so far you know I
can't imagine anybody wouldn't relate to
this you don't have to be a boy it's
just you know it's about growing up it's
about life you know and you can really
feel that so yeah have you seen this you
know let me know what you think
otherwise that's it for now until next
time I am Jerry and Cheers